hey everyone Bang Bang all right here we
go the Bitcoin spot ETF this is the big
week so I've got 12 predictions for you
on what is going to happen with Bitcoin
spot ETF first I believe that we are
going to see the approval on Wednesday
and then the funds will start trading on
Thursday this is important because
historically people were worried maybe
the approval is going to happen and then
it'll be one or two weeks in between
when it starts trading no I think it's
going to be a very very narrow and tight
time frame between when the approval
happens and then when it starts to trade
now the second one is that the ETF will
likely receive $2 billion in AUM in the
first 48 Hours $2 billion in the first
two days to put this in context there
was about a billion dollars that came
into the bitto which was the Futures
based Bitcoin ETF and that came in about
the first 48 hours I think that this one
is going to be at least 2x that so $2
billion in the first two days is what
the inflows are going to look like that
number is surprising a lot of people in
traditional Finance this would smash the
record for all ETF filings and it would
would put a brand new all-time record
out there that is unlikely to see
another asset that could come along and
beat it but who knows but $2 billion in
the first 48 hours is kind of my base
case so what's going to happen in the
first 30 days in my opinion that's going
to be $5 billion in AUM $5 billion in
AUM gold is about a 100 billion so it be
like 5% of the gold market coming into
this ETF in the first 30 days that would
be a very very hot start so two billion
in the first two days five ion coming in
the first 30 days now outside of
grayscale my next prediction grayscale
has the most assets today they are only
lowering their fee from 2% to 1 and a
half% which we'll talk about in a second
but who is going to be the big winner
here I think that black rock will emerge
with the most assets outside of
grayscale everyone's going to do well
everyone's going to get assets there's
going to be a ton of capital inflow but
it will be uh a black rock winner coming
out of this and I think that gry skill
will be number one just cuz the ass ass
they already have enough assets won't
leave for Black Rock to be able to
Eclipse them but it'll be grayscale one
and then Black Rock will be the big new
winner or the big new entrance into the
market next up marketing spend I think
that there will be at least $100 million
spent on marketing in the first year uh
across all of these different uh spot
ETF issuers I recently learned from the
guys over at Bloomberg intelligence that
you can't actually advertise the ETF in
the commercial so you can advertise
Bitcoin you can the name of the issuer
but you can't advertise the ETF itself
and so uh that $100 million I think is
going to come into the market you're
going to see it everywhere you see it on
podcasts you can see in newsletters
Billboards you see it at the airport
you're can see it on bus terminals
you're going to see all sorts of
different things on TV Etc that leads to
the next prediction which is number six
there's at least one Bitcoin spot ETF ad
that we played during the Super Bowl so
we're going get a Super Bowl ad for the
Bitcoin spot ETFs which really just
means that we're going to have a Super
Bowl based Bitcoin ad I don't know who's
going to do it I don't know what the
ad's going to say but you got to think
in this entire marketing award that all
these ETF issuers are going to go
through somebody's going to pull the
trigger somebody's going to spend the
money and somebody's going to do that
Super Bowl ad so what next my next
prediction number seven financial
advisors around the country they're
going to put 1 to 3% of their client's
assets in uh my friend Mark yuso uh
recently brought up this great idea
where if it comes from on high some of
these platforms some of the financial
advisor networks if they say to their
financial advisers okay our base case
our model now includes 1% Bitcoin all of
the financial advisors within that
Network they got to go put 1% and so it
is not going to happen overnight but yes
financial advisors now that they have
access to an ETF 1 to 3% is going to be
the allocation that will likely lead to
tens of billions and eventually over
$100 billion coming in from financial
advisers and their clients assets number
eight at least one Sovereign wealth fund
within the first 12 months announces
that they have bought the Bitcoin ETF I
don't think it's because they're saying
hey we're going to hold the Bitcoin
they're obviously just buying any ETF
it's not the same thing as owning a
Bitcoin itself but I think what they are
going to do is they're going to say okay
just like we manage our Equity portfolio
if you've got tens of billions or
hundreds of billions of dollars of
assets getting some exposure probably
makes sense and so at least one
Sovereign wealth fund within the first
12 months will go ahead and they'll buy
the Bitcoin spot ETF number nine
speculation around the ethereum spot ETF
will intensify before the end of q1 Once
Bitcoin is out there all of a sudden
people are going to turn and say hey we
want the ethereum one as well and so
again I don't know if it gets approved
by the end of q1 but I do think that the
speculation begins to really really
intensify similar to what's happened
here with the Bitcoin one and we
eventually do get that ethereum uh spot
ETF as well number 10 non-bitcoin ETF
issuers begin allocating some of their
AUM into the Bitcoin spot ETF so you
have all these ETF all these fund
managers mutual funds Etc that are out
there they can either directly invest
into underlying Securities or assets
from their funds or sometimes they will
actually just buy other funds to get
exposure to an asset and so if
somebody's out there wants to get
exposure to bitcoin but they can't
actually hold the Bitcoin or don't want
to hold the Bitcoin buying ETF may
actually be a pretty good way to do it
and so what does that mean that means
that there's going to be some level of
net new capital inflow that is coming
from funds that are already allocated to
mutual funds ETFs Etc we've seen a
couple of people go ahead and update
their perspectus up to 15% of AUM to put
into the fund I don't think that that's
necessarily that groundbreaking but I do
think we will see some of them start to
do it uh my next one number 11 I think
we're on is bitcoin's volatility
drastically reduces in the next three
years this one is not going to make a
lot of people in the Bitcoin Community
happy but I just think it's the truth as
you get a larger holder base as you get
a holder base that is not used to
actually holding all the time what you
are likely to see is that you're going
to see that dampened volatility that
dampened volatility will likely lead to
less asymmetry less asymmetry means that
some of the people who have been really
interested in Bitcoin they become a
little bored right if Bitcoin isn't just
going to go parabolic then all of a
sudden the ETFs there's lots of
positives but maybe one of the downsides
is just that there is that dampened
volatility and so asymmetry has
disappeared number 12 is that bitcoin's
compound annual growth rate Falls to 20%
within 5 years so Bitcoin compound
annual growth rate has fluctuated
between 50 to 150% depending on where we
are in the different Market Cycles at
the top of 2021 it was over 100% today
it's over 50% but under 100% I think
that we will start to see it perform
much more like a traditional asset uh
within the next five years because of
that dampen volatility again we're going
to see that dampen volatility in the
next three years within five years I
think the average compound annual growth
rate of Bitcoin will be about 20% so
it'll be two times the stock market is a
way to think about it um and you know
again great return if you can compound
every year year-over-year at 20% that's
amazing but I don't think that that's
necessarily what a lot of the people
seeking asymmetry are really looking for
from Bitcoin now I have a bonus
prediction I said 12 but I I lied I got
12 or I got more than 12 I got a Bonus
one around the fees so we look at the
fees Grace scale used to charge 2% uh
management fee they now are dropping to
one and a half per. we recently got a
bunch of updates in terms of what people
are going to charge so we've got uh uh
Arc 21 shares they're going to be
charging 25 basis points in the steady
state uh I shares Black Rock they're
going to be charging uh 30 basis points
we have bitwise coming in at the lowest
so far at 24 basis points Vanek and
Wisdom Tree Vanek is at 25 basis points
Wisdom Tree is at uh 50 basis points we
then have uh Invesco 0.59 and Fidelity
is at 39 as well so what does all of
this mean there's a fee war going on and
if that fee war is happening then you're
you are going to see them all keep
cutting fees to try to compete with each
other it's a mimetic thing there's
competition but my bonus prediction is
that we will see all of the crypto
exchanges and custodians drop their fees
by 50% or more within the next three
years and a lot of it is going to be due
to the fact that you are going to get
such big pressure from these ETF holders
Gabor gabox po posted uh earlier this
morning he's like wait a second it's
cheaper to go buy the ETF and hold it
for an entire year than it is to do one
transaction on some cryptocurrency
exchanges and so if it's cheaper to just
hold the ETF for a year then why would I
go onto this exchange and buy because
it's going to cost me more money in the
long run so I do think that we're going
to see a massive cut 50% is my
prediction within the next three years
where we are going to see custodians and
exchanges have to cut their fees down in
order to compete with the ETF we know
the fee Wars are happening in the ETF
world but now we're going to see it
happen to these other players as well
there's a whole lot of stuff going on
this is going to get absolutely crazy so
buckle up I think that we're going to
get it Wednesday is approval day
Thursday we start trading I think it's
going to hit you know bang bang as some
people may say uh and it'll be quite
exciting so I appreciate you all
listening watching and I hope that you
guys have a great week